bonjour et bienvenue dans ce club le
magazine santé de la rédaction au
sommaire ce mois ci nous parlons d'un
atelier consacré à la prévention du
surpoids cela se déroule à traves nous
sommes allés à verser poursuivre la
construction la réalisation d'une maison
de retraite pour personnes âgées co
financé à la fois par défaut au public
et privé c'est une première à voisins le
bretonneux l'association des paralysés
de france propose deux cours d'arts
plastiques pour ses adhérents des
personnes en situation de handicap nous
avons rencontré certaines d'entre elles
puis l'actualité de ce mois c'est la
deuxième semaine de l'autonomie à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines check up qui
était forcément
deuxième édition d'un colloque pour
parler de l'autonomie les premières lois
sur la prise en charge de la perte
d'autonomie en france date de 1962 avec
l'instauration des aides à domicile
cinquante ans plus tard quel bilan
dresser et bien cet universitaire n'a
pas la langue de bois
effectivement il ya ce rapport le roc de
62 qui dit les gens de rester chez eux
faut les y aider et la cour des comptes
en 2005 10 est grosso modo en 40 ans on
a fait des choses mais aucun
gouvernement quel qu'il soit n'a été
jusqu'au bout le courage c'est mettre un
peu plus d'argent notamment sur les
services à domicile on sait que les gens
veulent rester chez eux donc on sait
aujourd'hui que l'essentiel du travail
est fait par les familles beaucoup trop
bernard ennuyer pointe également du
doigt les manques de cohérence entre les
différents dispositifs à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines exemple
pourrait venir de gier handicap un
groupement de coopération qui intervient
dans le domaine de la gérontologie et du
handicap c'est lui qui est à l'origine
de ce colloque ça va dans la bonne
direction bien plus que dans d'autres
départements donc je peux dire que je
vis ici avec plaisir la perte
d'autonomie ne se limite pas aux
personnes âgées des salariés peuvent
également être concernés autre exemple
de mise en commun le réseau yvelines
santé travail nous avons des équipes qui
sont des équipes pluridisciplinaires
puisque souvent il ya plusieurs ou couto
surtout plusieurs types de problèmes il
ya un air de une juriste psychologue et
une assistante sociale nous appliquons
une méthodologie qui est reconnue
nationalement
cette année yvelines santé travail à
prêter 600 dossiers et 80 % des salariés
ont été maintenus en emploi en matière
de perte d'autonomie le meilleur conseil
est de prendre contact avec la
coordination gérontologique de son
territoire un projet de loi sur cette
question pourrait être présenté en 2014
par la ministre de la santé
attrape 20% des enfants seraient en
situation de surpoids voire même
d'obésité un atelier de prévention est
organisée à leur intention et à celle
évidemment de leurs parents à raison de
cinq semaines jusqu'au mois de décembre
une réunion détendue autour d'un thé et
mais une réunion pour discuter d'un
thème délicat le surpoids et l'obésité
chez les plus jeunes la maison des
parents de trappes propose aux enfants
et à leurs parents un programme de cinq
séances jusqu'au mois de décembre
le principe c'est leur parler d'
équilibre alimentaire de leur apprendre
à manger de façon équilibrée tout en
gardant le plaisir donc on aborde
diverses thématiques théorique mais
aussi pratique puisqu'il ya deux
ateliers dédiés à la cuisine l'un est
dédié à la préparation d'un petit
déjeuner goûter et l'autre est dédié à
la préparation d'un repas et qui
aimeraient un repas équilibré justement
qu'est ce que c'est il doit se
constituer d'un produit laitier d'une
céréales de fruits de légumes et d'un
apport protidique apportées par les
oeufs le poisson ou la viande des
notions que l'on doit très souvent
répété pour qu'elle soit entendu car la
cause et de santé publique attrape par
exemple 20 % des enfants sont en
surpoids et en obésité et il est
important d'intervenir le plus tôt
possible dans la vie du jeune on ne
parlera pas de régime alimentaire dans
ce cas là mais simplement pour l'enfant
le en bas âge c'est contrôler la
quantité de sucre les bonbons les
viennoiseries et les sucreries qu'on lui
donne et puis des petits les inciter à
bouger car un repas équilibré ne se
résume pas seulement à ceux qui se
trouvent dans l'assiette il est aussi
essentiel dans l'enfance de pratiquer
une activité sportive
la prochaine rencontre aura lieu le 6
octobre au matin les suivantes ses
talons jusqu'au 9 décembre
une première dans le département le
public et le privé s'accordent pour
réaliser une résidence pour personnes
âgées cela se passe à versailles et
originalité les habitants peuvent
participer au projet explications
c'est une première dans les yvelines le
public et le privé investisse ensemble
dans un établissement pour personnes
âgées le centre hospitalier de
versailles la clinique médicale de la
porte verte et la ville de versailles se
sont réunis au sein d'une société
coopérative d'intérêt collectif à
laquelle s'ajoute une structure
solidaire entreprendre pour humaniser la
dépendance on as de ne pas loin de 2000
actionnaires qui conclut aujourd'hui en
fait à travers une épargne qui n'a pas
encore une fois qu'il n'a pas une
vocation en fait
sont des dividendes a bien évidemment
mais en fait les gens qui investissent
ils entendent effectivement un résultat
les superbes résultats sociale ce projet
nécessite 20 millions d'euros
d'investissement assuré en majorité par
un prêt locatif social pour compléter le
budget une originalité les versailles et
ont la possibilité d'investir en
souscrivant des parts sociales à hauteur
de 20 euros
le chantier est en fait la rénovation de
l'établissement lépine providence
abandonné pour malfaçons et qui devait
accueillir 200 résidents un nombre qui
avait fait bondir la mairie de
versailles ça nous a paru monstrueux
tu es une énorme maison de la
vulnérabilité et c'était contraire à ce
que la population nous renvoyer comme
demande et c'est de là qu'on s'est dit
mais comment pouvons-nous répondre à
cette obligation de projet architectural
mal fini qui a besoin d'être repris et
de répondre aux besoins de la population
la structure proposera 112 places dont
quatre places d'hébergement temporaire
mais aussi 12 places d'accueil de jour
et 160 places de services soins
infirmiers à domicile dont 10
spécialisée alzheimer l'ouverture de
l'établissement lépine providence est
prévue début 2016
l'association des paralysés de france
propose des cours d'arts plastiques à
des personnes en situation de handicap
cela se passe dans leurs locaux à
voisins le bretonneux et nous avons
rencontré certains des adhérents
ghislaine le nouvel découvre la
linogravure sur une plaque elle
reproduit un tableau qu'elle a choisi
les nymphéas de monet le geste des mains
élan ghislaine souffre d'un handicap
moteur depuis l'enfance
j'essaie de faire au mieux
faire au mieux et faire bien une fois
par semaine des ateliers d'arts
plastiques sont ainsi proposés par
l'association des paralysés de france
installée à voisins le bretonneux on
essaye de s'adapter
avec les moyens du bord
et puis on trouve des tas d'astuces
selon ce qu'ont fait la suisse par
exemple
justement en fait j'ai trouvé d'autres
marques pour m'aider à te dire leur
plaque et après moi chez les restes ici
dans cet atelier de peinture et de
gravure huit élèves sont inscrits ils
sont handicapés moteurs pour la plupart
le temps de l'atelier on oublie un peu
tôt pour déjà voir les copines et puis à
progresser dans la peinture au au début
je savais pas du tout peindre à
maintenant j'arrive mieux à faire des
dessins je me débrouillais déjà des
choses comme ça c'est une évasion
c'est oublier leur des petits soucis de
la vie quotidienne comme tout le monde
c'est pas toujours simple mais justement
on essaie d'évoluer 1 pour progresser
malgré ses difficultés voilà se dire
qu'on peut quand même évolué pourquoi
c'est vraiment dans l'idée d'une prise
de confiance en soi et donc voilà
évoluer dans ce qu'on peut faire en arts
plastiques
ces ateliers sont également ouverts aux
personnes valides une exposition commune
de peinture et de sculpture aura lieu à
la fin de l'année
avant de nous quitter noter ses
prochains rendez vous sentez une
formation sur la santé bucco-dentaire
sera animée par le docteur mougel depuis
la salle du conseil à l'hôtel
d'agglomération
à noter également à partir du 11 octobre
que débute la semaine du goût avec
plusieurs manifestations dans
l'agglomération mais notamment deux à la
verrière le 11 octobre entre 11h et 13h
devant le magasin intermarché et le 17
octobre à la maison quartier du bois de
l'étang et puis la caisse primaire
d'assurance maladie des yvelines lance
les ateliers sont actifs de répondre à
toutes les questions les plus fréquentes
au tour de l'ain santé prochain atelier
le 18 octobre depuis lippé s attrape
check up c'est fini merci de votre
attention prochain rendez vous le 2
novembre d'ici là portez vous bien
non